jason statham kommt nach deutschland und
dieser der fleißigste action-star
aktuell der welt kennt ja aus den crank
filmen oder auch aus transporter und
christoph hat leider keine zeit er
schafft es nicht nach berlin zu fliegen
um ihn zu interviewen und hat sich
gedacht schicke ich doch den blick aus
der filmfabrik der kann mit filmen kann
er wahrscheinlich auch mit den filmstars
ist jetzt die möglichkeit eure fragen an
jason statham zu stellen entweder hier
unten in den kommentaren oder als video
antwort falls er nicht wie das mit der
video antwort geht schaut einfach eine
infobox nach dann wird das erklärt und
mit ein bisschen glück ist eure frage
demnächst schon dabei die ich dann jason
statham stellen darf also eure fragen
abmarsch geht's ich freue mich drauf